in graduating their first rescue canine
unit Caesars also had several
demonstrations where the dogs were able
to detect weapons throughout this room
since Caesar's Entertainment Security
team began building its canine Fleet in
2018 most of its dogs came from Europe
now they are staying local Steve
Martinez who leads the canine program
says they worked with the animal
foundation basically our team members
can come to work with peace of mind that
they don't have to worry about
any incidents occurring on our property
because our dogs are here to deter it
and prevent it
this is Chase a three-year-old German
Shepherd he was found abandoned at a
park in Summerlin he underwent 160 hours
of training to sniff out guns that
people may try to bring to one of
Caesar's properties Justin Walker is his
Handler and once he sits I give him a
reward and that would be kind of the
indication that he's alerted on
something
because it has nine canines they cover
all of its properties you may see one of
them in a hotel casino While others work
behind the scenes Eric golbieski has
been with Caesars for 22 years
constantly evaluating ways to enhance
safety safety has become top of mind for
tourists and visitors and our guests and
as that happened we knew we had to
evolve and bring that into our program
Caesar is already working with another
rescue dog from the animal foundation to
introduce as part of a security Fleet
reporting in Las Vegas Joshua progero
eight news now